je pense que du point de vue de ceux de
l'impact de cette crise sur le travail
il ya vraiment plein plein de choses à
dire je pense que d'abord l'importance
du travail va le faire que croître et
embellir parce qu'on va en être privé et
on va aussi être privé des dimensions de
dimensions assez négligée jusqu'à
maintenant de travail le fait justement
qu'on puisse toucher qu'on puisse se
parle dès qu'on puisse voir nos
expressions qu'on puisse être ensemble
qu'on puisse être dans un collectif
résistant à des consignes trop fort
voilà donc je pense que ça va renforcer
l'importance accordée au travail
concernant télétravail trouve que c'est
à la fois fantastique qu'on puisse
continuer à communiquer avec toutes ces
tous ces dispositifs moi j'ai continué à
faire cours à mes collègues et moi en
compte il va faire court tous les tous
les jours mais évidemment il ya des
inconvénients énorme télétravail
l'isolément du télétravail seule façon à
son écran du coup le risque que des
consignes absolument intenable soient
donnés par les employeurs aux aux
télétravailleurs et puis évidemment le
brouillage des frontières entre la vie
de travail et d'accueil au travail je
pense notamment à ce qu'on donne aux
enfants où c'est très très très
compliqué de concilier le travail et
leur travail et je pense qu'on est en
train de re dupliquer au sein de ce
confinement
les différences de genre dans le partage
des tâches domestiques et familiales
notamment qui était en oeuvre auparavant
que ça va être encore plus fort ça va
être renforcée
[Musique]